[Music]
hello welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my
name is Angela lomak Kang I'm glad that
you've tuned in you are going to be
blessed by this program and thank you
for your prayers and support of this
worldwide Ministry well I have something
I want to share with you when you buy a
car particularly a new car you get a
manual and in that manual is a thick
manual and there's so many details in
that manual how to turn on the light how
to turn it headlights turn it off uh
wipers off and on little simple things
you get from that manual well today the
word of God is our manual not just today
every day of our life the word of God is
our manual and that's what we will be
using the word of God well we have a
wonderful panel and I'm going to
introduce them right now
to my right is Ian vandol Ian welcome
Hey thank you Angie thank you for having
me I'm excited that you're going to be a
part of this program you're a 3abn
producer You Preach at our church yes
you teach Sabbath School I do you do so
many things you're in pastoral also yes
sometimes the Lord affords me time to be
there as well yes yes and so and he's
also a military guy a veteran amen so
thank you for your for what you do for
us here in America and what you have
done and thank you for being on the
panel oh thank you Angel all right next
to you is Daniel welcome back Daniel
thank you it's good to be here Angela
and I just I really appreciate this
program I'm happy to be on the program
today but I I hope it encourages people
just wet's their appetite to get into
and study these questions on their own
yes now you get a lot of questions don't
you up in pastoral they come by text and
email and by phone and uh sometimes face
to face amen thank you right in front of
me is the love of my life Pastor John
mang tell the world honey I'll tell the
whole world who you are yes welcome
honey and what do you think of Bible Q&A
it always surprises me what people ask
you know some of you ask questions that
I haven't even thought of and I thought
that's interesting so thank you for
those questions it drives us back to the
Bible and my bottom line is the Bible is
the final Authority so thank you for
that yeah always learn something yes yes
it is well the three panelists we have
we have questions so if you have
questions let me show you how you can
send your questions in if you want to
email us you can go to Bible QA 3abn.org
official now the questions today are
three minute questions and we have one
four-minute question and I'm just
excited about this panel and I'm excited
about the questions so remember if you
have questions send them in and we'll
send them to our panel and they will go
from the word of God and remember
nothing less than a whole Bible can make
a whole Christian and let's have Ian
open with prayer absolutely
our loving Heavenly Father Lord we just
thank you for this day that you have
given us we thank you for the life that
you have given us and just the air that
we breathe there are so many things that
we should praise your name for father
and we praise your name to have this
opportunity to just study with you to
learn and grow closer to you and I just
pray that your Holy Spirit would be
present with us that you would just fill
us with the words that you would have us
to speak and that those who are watching
or listening right now that they would
just be touched by the things that are
presented today and that we would all GR
in knowledge of you Lord we love you we
thank you and as always we praise you in
Jesus name amen amen amen thank you for
that prayer well are you ready for these
challenging questions get your Bibles
get your pens write down these these
answers from the word of God all right
now we'll start with Pastor LMA Kang and
this is a 4minute question and the
question is where in the Bible does it
say you need to to be baptized in the
name of Jesus Christ and speak in
tongues to be considered saved this is
from Harold in Georgia Harold thank you
for that question now the Bible does not
teach unless we are baptized and speak
in tongues we are saved the Bible does
teach that baptism is a prerequisite to
salvation but speaking in tongues is not
I'll give you an example we'll start
with the baptism part mark
16:16 he who believes and is B baptized
Jesus said we be saved but he who does
not believe will be condemned so you
find belief and baptism go hand in hand
but not baptism and tongues as an
Evidence of Salvation because tongues is
a gift we are not saved by gifts the
Lord Never Said by their gifts you'll
know them notice what he says in Matthew
7:
18-2 a good tree cannot bear bad fruit
nor can a bad tree be bear good fruit
fruit every tree that does not bear good
fruit is cut down and thrown into the
fire and here's the key therefore by
their fruit fruits you will know them
we're not known by our gifts and this is
very important because a lot of
Christians today have really really good
gifts but they are not displaying the
fruits they might be able to sing well
and preach well and teach well but they
could be mean and and short uh tempered
and angry the Bible says wait a minute
wait a minute love joy peace
longsuffering gentleness meekness
patience look for those fruits and and
you'll know that they're connected to me
because the vine connected to the branch
and the branch of flowing into the vine
together you find that they're producing
fruit as evidence of salvation but many
teach that speaking in tongues and this
is something that happened in the early
1920s and late 1920s early 1930s a
movement called glossolalia in America
where people began to say in order for
you to be saved you've got to speak in
tongues as evidence that's not the Bible
the Bible doesn't teach that so the
question is where do tongues come into
the picture when it comes to those who
are following the lord well let's go one
of the basic examples in scripture you
find in the book of Acts acts chap 2: 4
and
5 the Lord was giving the disciples the
ability as galileans to take the gospel
to the world and here's what he did acts
2:4 and they were all filled with the
Holy Spirit and began to speak with
other tongues as the spirit gave them
utterance speaking in tongu did not
begin on the day of Pentecost speaking
in other tongues began on the day of
Pentecost meaning simply other languages
they spoke in the language of the
galileans but they had to reach the
entire world and if you notice verse 5
of Acts chapter 2 and there were
dwelling in Jerusalem Jews devout men
from every nation under Heaven how can I
an American with an English uh language
carry the gospel to every nation under
Heaven one of two ways go to school and
learn their languages or have the Holy
Spirit equip me immediately and that's
exactly what happened on the day of
Pentecost and the evidence of that is
how those who heard these galileans
speak notice what their testimony was
Acts chapter 2 and
ver8 and how is it that we hear each in
our own language in which we were born
those from other parts of the world said
they're speaking in the language where
we were born evidence that it's not some
gibberish that only the Lord knows or
you have to speak that language to hide
from the devil and then verse 11 once
again the testimony from the hearers we
hear them speak in our own tongue the
wonderful works of God and finally the
Apostle Paul addressing this issue with
the cor Corinthians who had many many
languages in their congregation it was a
coastal city a multicultural City he
asked the question when this issue of
what language should we speak in and
what gift should we ask for he said in 1
Corinthians 12:30 do all have the gift
of healings the answer is no do all
speak with tongues the answer is no do
all interpret the answer is no so to be
saved you have to believe in Jesus
Christ and be baptized but if he knows
you're trying to reach somebody in
another language he may give you the
gift of tongues wow that was beautiful
well said and 3abn is used in AI right
that's right I speak in other languages
through AI through AI right Japes reach
other people not to communicate with my
brethren of the same language right and
it is going into all the world thank you
for that all right Daniel yours is also
a four-minute question and here we go
can you please explain in detail what
the Abomination is and what makes it
desolate Daniel 1211 and Matthew
24:15 this is from Joseph in
Arizona thank you Joseph for asking this
question from The Book of Daniel and
Matthew Daniel is my name as well and so
I appreciate this book and questions
that arise from it to understand well
before I get to reading those two texts
let's look at the words very briefly an
Abomination this is a detestable
offensive thing that brings horror and
it is essentially in opposition to the
character of God and the Plan of
Salvation in the Old Testament that word
Abomination referred to idol worship and
the the rituals that went along with it
like human sacrifice and religious
prostitution so that's an abomination in
opposition to God's character in The
Plan of Salvation to make desolate
desolate means to be laid waste and
completely devastated so as to be
appalling all right something is just
stripped bare of all its usefulness so
the Abomination that makes desolate or
the abomination of desolation as some
translated it is a detestable Act of
idolatry that opposes God and his
character and ultimately makes desolate
by undercutting The Plan of Salvation so
so now let's get into those three those
two texts and I got to tell you there's
three different applications to this
phrase and I'm going to be ultra brief
on here which means some of the detail
is lacking because we have a small time
period Daniel 12:1 says and from the
time that the daily sacrifice is taken
away and the abomination of desolation
is set up there shall be
1,290 days now this is a Time prophecy
and it's set in the context of a
historical progression of of prophesied
events and without too much detail here
that time indicated for the beginning of
this prophecy is ad. 538 and what
happened in that year is there was the
setting up of a religious organization
that was no longer opposed that put
itself into the place of Jesus Christ's
saving work as the mediator in place of
Jesus this was a Papal religious
organization that substituted faith in
human mediators for the work of Jesus
Christ this undercuts The Plan of
Salvation which is putting faith in
Jesus Christ for salvation so that's
that's Daniel 12:11 now Jesus in Matthew
24:1 15 he is looking back and using
what Daniel said and building upon that
to show that the same pattern of events
happens in other ways and so his
disciples have heard what Jesus said
about uh the temple being cast down one
stone no not one stone upon another and
they say two questions they say Lord uh
tell us when will these things be and
what will be the sign of your coming and
of the end of the age they think they're
asking one question but they're really
asking two about the fall of Jerusalem
uh the tearing apart of that physical
Temple and about the coming of the son
of man the second coming and so the
first application of this a prophecy
applies to the fall of Jerusalem as
Jesus Blends those two events together
as he answers this question for them and
so uh the temple represents Jesus saving
work and the abomination of desolation
was when the temple was desecrated
ultimately by first by the Jews who used
the temple space as their last stand
their military uh you know fight against
the Romans that was their Fortress now
of course in what they had been doing by
rejecting Jesus as Messiah they had also
been desecrating the temple that pointed
forward to his ministry and so that
abomination of desolation ultimately led
to the complete desolation of the temple
itself the final application is to the
time before Jesus returns God is our
creator and his government is built upon
love which is freedom of conscience the
abomination of desolation before Jesus
comes is when man-made when when human
governments Unite with religion to
enforce man-made laws to strip you of
your conscien driven rights to worship
God according to the seventh day Sabbath
that honors him as Creator now when that
happens that will strip when when people
accept that uh first day Sabbath instead
of the 7eventh day Sabbath that strips
out really the vitals of your spiritual
Faith by setting up an idol in the place
of the Creator so that is the
abomination of desolation before Jesus
comes replacing the Sabbath day uh
officially uh enforced so that's a very
brief explanation uh I'm sure there are
other programs on this network that will
explain in Greater detail wow it's a lot
to cover in four minutes when you say
first day Sabbath explain that real
quick first the first day is not the
Sabbath the first day of the week so
replacing the seventh day Sabbath with
honoring God by the first day of the
week instead yeah thank you well said
okay Ian here's your question can you
explain uh what 1 Corinthians 3:15 is
saying this is from someone in
Pennsylvania didn't give a name all
right well thank you so much for your
question I'm going to go right ahead and
just start reading what that verse is 1
Corinthians 3:15 says if anyone's work
is burned he will suffer loss but he
himself will be saved yet so as through
fire now the question of what this verse
means is actually extremely important
this is uh a solemn reminder to all of
us as Christians and in order to really
understand this though you have to get
it in its entire context so you're going
to have to go back and we're going to
start in verse 9 of 1 Corinthians uh
chapter 3 so starting in verse 9 it says
for we are God's fellow workers you are
God's field you are God's Building
according in to the grace of God which
was given to me as a wise master builder
I have laid the foundation and another
Builds on it but let each one take heed
how he builds on it so to be mindful of
the things that we are teaching now in
verse 11 it says for no other Foundation
can anyone lay than that which is laid
which is Jesus Christ verse 12 now if
anyone Builds on this foundation with
gold silver precious stones wood hay
straw each one's work will become clear
for the day will declare it because it
will be revealed by fire and the fire
will test each one's work and what sort
it is now here's what's important verse
14 and 15 if anyone's work which he has
built on it endures he will see receive
a reward now 15 if anyone's work is
burned he will suffer loss but he
himself will be saved yet so as through
fire so once we accept Christ into our
lives we become workers for him just
like it says in verse 9 and also in
verse 11 it tells us that no teaching no
Doctrine nothing can be built upon
except that of the foundation which is
Jesus Christ so what Paul is teaching us
is exceptionally important to
individuals like pastors preachers Bible
teachers even evangelists but this
really applies to anyone that shares the
Gospel of Jesus with others so in uh
what you're going to see here is there's
actually two groups of teachers and two
groups of people who are brought to
Christ the first group is found in in uh
verse 14 and these are those who are
teaching the truth uh they're leading
people in sincerity through the guidance
of the Holy Spirit uh they're building a
kingdom that's going to stand the test
uh and trials now the other group is
found in verse 15 these are the ones who
neglect to teach the truth that is in
its Purity and they're actually
Gathering converts who are not holy in
heart or in life uh they're bringing
material that is not going to stand the
test and because of that they're going
to suffer loss so here's an interesting
thing though about verse 15 so the one
who is actually teaching falsely can
actually still be saved and the reason
because of that is because through their
trials they have realized their wrong
and they have genuinely repented of
their sins and have gone to the Lord and
asked for forgiveness um and that's why
we need to take heed as as um Paul says
to his first letter to Timothy take heed
to yourself and to the doctrine continue
in them for in doing this you will save
both yourself and those who hear you so
is it exceptionally important that we
are studying the word of God and that
what we are teaching is actually going
to stand help individuals stand in the
test of Trials and fire yes thank you
for that repentance is important I'm
glad you said that that's right yeah a
lot of churches are leaving out
repent yeah so that's very important
thank you okay pastor lomma Kang here is
your question James chapter 1 vers verse
13 says that God does not tempt anyone
in many other verses the Bible says that
God tests us like Deuteronomy 8:2 and
Jeremiah
1710 what's the difference between
tempted and tested this is from Jonathan
in Nevada okay I'll read Deuteronomy 8:2
and Jeremiah 17 10 very quickly
Deuteronomy 8:2 and you shall remember
that the Lord your God LED you all the
way these 40 years in the wilderness to
Humble you and test you to know what was
in your heart whether you would keep his
Commandments or not in Jeremiah 17:10 I
the Lord search the heart I test the
mind even to give every man according to
his ways according to the fruit of his
own doing now let's look at the
difference between Temptation and
testing yeah or being tempted and being
tested Temptation occurs when your
sinful lusts and desire
are presented to you to entice you look
at James
1:14 I'm going to read that and just
tell you something about how God does
not use these tools to test you James
1:14 but each one is tempted when he is
drawn away by his own desires and
enticed and if you read the verses
before that God does not God is not
tempted nor does he tempt anyone with
evil so but James is talking about those
things that are uh a part of our lusts
and our desires that is what temptation
is testing on the other hand is the Lord
looking at the veracity of your
connection to him I'll give you an
example if somebody's preparing for a
weightlifting contest I'll say well the
opposition that guy could lift 400 lbs
dead lift how much can you lift that's a
test not a temptation but if I said to a
kid hey you little scrawny kid can you
lift 400 sounds that's a Temptation if
he's filled with pride he might tried
and hurt himself the difference is
simply one has a desire that's boiling
up in him the Bible also calls it a lust
and the devil says
hey you want to have a drink that's a
Temptation the Lord says are you thirsty
speak to the Rock if you speak to the
Rock I'll give you water but don't hit
it that's a test and Moses had that test
that he failed the Lord said speak to
the Rock in his anxiety and his
frustration he smot The Rock he hit the
rock Moses was not being tempted Moses
was being tested Temptation comes when
you have a desire in you that is boiling
up that you have not yet gotten rid of
and that's why the Lord made it very
clear in Exodus 20:3 that we must make
sure that we have no other gods before
him and finally Joshua
24:15 you got to choose whom you're
going to serve and look look at the test
he says if it seems evil to you to serve
the Lord choose for yourselves this day
whom you will serve whether the gods
which your father served which are on
the other side of the river or the gods
of the amorites in whose land you dwell
but notice his response and this should
be our response when testing comes and
even when Temptation comes but as for me
in my house we will serve the Lord by
Christ's strength you can stand the test
and endure the Temptation thank you for
that you know life is a test
everything about is a test yeah in life
it is a test everyone goes through a
test but with Jesus we can pass that
test that's right amen amen thank you so
much okay Daniel here's your
question what does Genesis 32:28 mean
when God says to Jacob you have
struggled with God and with men and have
prevailed what struggle is he referring
to and how did J
Prevail this is from Ben in
Marius thank you Ben for this question
now let's look at Jacob who was the
prophesied son through whom God would
preserve the line that would lead to the
Messiah and uh as such the enemy of
souls really had it out for Jacob and
wanted him to be compromised and to be
unfit for Spiritual use and so he
tempted him and he partially succeeded
in getting Jacob to deceive his father
in Genesis CH 27 and that deception of
his father began a struggle with man and
with God essentially his brother Esau
was angry with him and he had to flee
from his brother's wrath he took Refuge
with his uncle laan uh and his and his
uh cousins laan's Sons but uh you can
read about the struggle that was caused
by being there among laan's family when
you look at Genesis
28-31 it was not an easy experience at
God's Direction though Jacob finally
after 20 years was directed to go back
home and face the 20-year-old wrath and
rage of his brother so on the on his
return Genesis chapter 32 Jacob spends a
night alone in prayer and as he is doing
that he's overtaken by a mighty enemy
who grabs hold of him and he begins to
fight this opponent as he would any
other human attacker until one touch
from the Divine finger
dislocates his hip and he realizes who
he's really fighting with it's God
himself and so he changes his tactics
instead of trying to get the upper hand
and defeat this person he's in conflict
with he starts to hold on tight and will
not let go of him with all the strength
he can muster so in verse 26 and he God
said let me go for the day breaks God
didn't need to ask Jacob permission to
let go of him he could do whatever he
want but he's essentially saying Jacob
let's get real now is the time and he
Jacob said I won't let you go unless you
bless me so he God said to him what is
your name and he said Jacob now here's
the real struggle with men it is the
struggle with you yourself and your sin
because his name Jacob meant deceiver so
God says let's get real the real
struggle is with self that's the man
you're fighting
and when Jacob gets real God responds by
changing his name so the conflict with
sin with with men is the conflict with
sin in ourselves and it's expressed in
how we deal with every other person and
the the victory is gained when we let go
of sin we hold on to Christ the conflict
with God is not getting the upper hand
because we can't but it is simply
clinging to God and holding on to his
Mercy as unworthy as we are and victory
is gained when we are forgiven of sin
and God changes our character the
conflict with man the conflict with God
all solved in the same way clinging to
Christ and his goodness and being
transformed by his character amen and
his name was changed from Jacob to
Israel wasn't it an overcomer we all can
overcome too by the blood of the Lamb
through Jesus thank you for that okay
Ian here's your question and it's from
the same person benon Marius it says
here in the Book of Daniel the meop
Persian kingdom is represented with the
symbols of a beer and a ram could you
please clarify this I thought each
symbol only had one meaning and that's
again from Ben in Marius all right Ben
thank you so much for your question um
one thing I would like to say is there's
actually three symbols that represent
Meo Persia so you could see in Daniel
chapter 2 that Meo Persia is represented
with chest and arms of silver and as you
suggested in Daniel 7 as a bear and
Daniel 8 as a ram but there are other
things that are even mentioned in Daniel
that have multiple symbols Babylon and
Daniel 2 is represented as a head of
gold Daniel chapter 7 is a lion with
Eagle's Wings and uh we also see Greece
again in the Book of Daniel in Daniel
chapter 2 a belly and thighs of bronze
in Daniel chapter 7 as a leopard and
Daniel 8 as a male goat so what the Book
of Daniel does is kind of like this
repeat and enlarge uh theme giving you
more characteristics and giving you more
information regarding um the prophetic
elements in its writings and we see this
all throughout the Bible where things
might have multiple symbols Jesus even
gave the Kingdom of Heaven multiple
symbols we see it all through Matthew
Chapter 13 where uh the Kingdom of
Heaven is represented as a mustard seed
also represented as leaven or a treasure
hidden in a field uh even the Devil
Himself has was given different symbols
in the Bible he's repres presented in
Genesis 3 as a serpent and Revelation 12
as a dragon and even 1 Peter 58 as a
roaring lion and just to give you some
other things even the word of God is
given multiple symbols uh Ephesians
chapter 6 the word of God is represented
as a sword uh in Luke 8 it's represented
as a seed as in Psalm 119 it's
represented as a light and even in
Jeremiah
2329 uh the word of God is represented
as a fire so there are multiple things
really that you can see throughout the
Bible where it's given multiple symbols
um to represent one thing even the holy
spirit is given multiple symbols as a
dove or a fire or wind or oil so you'll
see this theme throughout the whole
Bible um as far as things given multiple
symbols so hopefully that clarifies
things up for you as far as uh The Book
of Daniel in meal Persia and the kingdom
being represented by multiple symbols as
well that's right yeah thank you for
that well answered and maybe you've just
tuned in and you say I want to send a
question in well you can email us by
going to Bible QA
3abn.org
abnor official Okay so send your
questions in we'd love to answer them
with our distinguished Bible panel all
right Pastor L Kang you have a quick
short question and here it is where did
demons come from H well the Bible uses
the word demons and Devils
interchangeably depending on the
translation if you use the King James
version you find the word Devils used 55
times if you use the new King James
version you find the word demons used 49
times but in both translations the first
reference to either a demon or a devil
is Leviticus
17:7 and the last reference to a demon
or devil is revelation
18:2 but the question is where do they
come from Simply put demons are fallen
angels that were cast to the earth when
Satan or Lucifer was cast out of Heaven
Isaiah 14:14 how art thou fallen from
Heaven oh Lucifer son of the morning and
Revelation 12:4 tells you what happened
when he fell Revelation 12:4 his tail
drew a third of the stars of heaven and
threw them to the Earth so when he was
cast out one third of the Angels
defected with him they were also evicted
they took his side by the multitude of
his trading he traded light for Darkness
Truth for error and deceived onethird of
the Angels the good news is 2/3 St still
remained the Bible talks about this in
Revelation 12: 79 and war broke out in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon that's Michael Christ
the highest of the Angels the one above
the Angels Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon and the dragon and his
angels fought but they did not Prevail
nor was a place found for them in heaven
any longer and so it says so the Great
Dragon was cast out verse 9 of
Revelation 12 that Serpent of old called
the devil and Satan who deceives the
whole world he was cast to the Earth and
his angels were cast out with him
something very interesting no matter the
translation in Revelation 12 verse 7-9
verse 9 refers to him in King James and
new King James as the devil The Serpent
of all and Satan but now we find demons
and devils are the same but now here's
one last part Revelation 16: 13- 14 when
you read those in either translation you
find in the King James version speaking
about the activity of unclean spirits
for they are the spirits of devils King
James version Revelation 16:14 they are
the spirits of devils but in the new
King James Revelation 16:14 they are the
spirits of demons so same Fallen Angels
Devils demons same exact thing demons
are also called and this is another
third part also called familiar spirits
from which we get the Hebrew word family
meaning some people might say you know
my mother died 5 years ago but she
visited me recently no that's a demon
that's a devil in the form of familiar
Spirit which is connected to the work of
mediums and the Bible says in Leviticus
20:6 do not have any connection with
mediums those people that are Conjuring
up evil spirits like the witch of Endor
so simply put the devil and demons are
the same they are Fallen Angels yeah
exactly they are fallen and and I'm glad
you explained about people that say oh
familiar Spirit dead mother came to
visit me it's a demon they've been
around long enough to know what your mom
looks like exactly sounds like and yeah
sounds like yeah yeah all of that thank
you for that okay Daniel this is a four
minute
question what day is a Sabbath day
kindly confirm by giving biblical proof
all right and you know we get this
question from time to time somewhat
frequently and it's important to return
to it because I know that there are
people who are either new to this uh
Network Three Angels Broadcasting
Network or they're new to this Bible
truth and so it's important to address
this again so let's trace the Sabbath
through scripture if I was at all
confusing about the seventh day and the
first day in my first question let's let
scripture tell us now so we'll go back
to the very beginning of the Bible in
Genesis chapter 1 starting with verse
five we have beginning the six days of
creation and they're described like this
the first day of creation is called the
first day and then the second day in
verse 8 and then verse 13 is the third
day and so forth through the fourth
fifth and sixth day and then we get to
Genesis 2: 2 to 4 uh 2 and 3 that says
on the seventh day God ended his work
which he had done and he rested on the
seventh day from all his work which he
had done then God blessed the seventh
day and Sanctified it because in it he
rested from all his work which he had
created and made so this is for all the
descendants of Adam and Eve for all time
there's no Nations now there's no
different families or Clans only one all
right seventh day Exodus chapter 16
we'll Zoom through to that part and this
is looking at verses 26 to 23 God is
dropping mana on the ground each day
except for the seventh day it says for
the people of Israel to eat and so the
Lord himself says in verse 23 tomorrow
is a Sabbath rest a holy Sabbath to the
Lord in verse 20 26 Moses confirms that
that Sabbath day is the seventh day so
there's no confusion about which day it
is at that point in history Exodus chap
20 God gives The Ten Commandments and in
verses 8 to 11 says remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy verse 10 the seventh
day is the Sabbath of the Lord your God
and verse 11 connects it back to
Creation because God created so that
seventh day in Genesis chapter 2 is the
Sabbath in Exodus 20 and the Lord
blessed the Sabbath day and hallowed it
the seventh day as the Sabbath is
confirmed again in Exodus chapter
35:2 now let's move on to Jeremiah 17:
19 to to 27 and I want you to know that
this is about 600 BC so we're moving
long into the future and Jeremiah says
thus says the Lord take heed to
yourselves and bear no burdens on the
Sabbath day that's verse 21 but that
whole section talks about the Sabbath no
correction as to which day just they're
they're looking at that seventh day
Sabbath and they're desecrating it
they're not dealing with it
appropriately same thing happens in
Nehemiah 13:1 15 uh there's no problem
with the day they got the day right but
they're now working on that day they're
harvesting they're they're treading the
wine press and things like that move to
acts 15: 21 and James is speaking and
listen to what he says he says for Moses
has had through many generations those
who preach him in every city being read
in the synagogue every Sabbath in other
words they look back and they say week
by week on the Sabbath it has not
changed up until that day and this is
after Jesus has died and resurrected and
ascended to heaven and they're looking
back and saying nothing has changed and
Jesus confirms that very thing uh in the
time of Jesus look at Matthew 12: 2 the
Pharisees accus Jesus disciples of doing
what is not lawful on the Sabbath nobody
said you got the Sabbath day wrong and
Jesus didn't correct them and say hey
you're wrong about the day what they
were doing is they were misusing the
Sabbath day and so in verse eight Jesus
says the son of man is Lord even of the
Sabbath confirmation is given in detail
in Luke 23:56 when Jesus rests in the
Tomb on the Sabbath according to the
Commandment that verse says you can look
through the book of Acts a number of
different texts including chapter 18:40
which is a we we know that's dated to
about
a.50 so we know that the Sabbath day had
not changed all the way to that point
all were in agreement on it and since
that time calendar records have
proceeded day by day with the Jewish
people and every other proceeding week
by week the Jews keeping the Sabbath one
week after the other we know what day it
was in the time of Jesus God confirmed
that and it's continued on every seventh
day every week uh the Sabbath day week
by week until then until we get to today
and praise the lord we have the Sabbath
and we know what it is and we can follow
God's will wow well said wow and the
Jews as a nation they still keep the
Sabbath but it's not the Jewish Sabbath
is it sabath for man it's made for man
thank you which we are mankind thank you
okay Ian let's go to your 4minute
question easy what is the unpardonable
sin this is from Ivonne in Jamaica all
right well thank you Ivonne from Jamaica
uh so this is a very common question one
I'm certain that we have answered here
on this program before but it is
definitely worth addressing again
because often when we think about the
unpardonable sin our mind starts to
wonder about what kind of sin out there
could actually be unpardonable you know
we we start to think about the worst
possible scenarios in our mind things
like murder or um you know adultery even
things like uh child trafficking you
know and uh there are some grotesque
things that man has done throughout
history and is actually recorded in the
Bible as well and uh we know though that
God is full of compassion uh we read in
Psalm chapter 86 verse1 15 where it says
but you oh Lord are God full of
compassion and gracious longsuffering
and abundant in Mercy and truth so what
possibly could be unpardonable because
we also think see characters in The
Bible such as manasse if uh you read in
2 Kings CH 21 and verse 6 speaking of
Manasseh it says also he made his son
pass through the fire meaning he
sacrificed his own son he practiced
sousing used witchcraft consulted
spiritists and mediums and he did much
evil in the sight of the Lord to provoke
him to anger so Manasseh did all of
these things yet we find out later that
as Manasseh was taken away uh captive
that he actually repented he prayed to
God and God heard his prayers and He
restored Manasseh even after all of
these things that he had done so what is
it that can't be forgiven and as Ivonne
from Jamaica asked what really is the
unpardonable sin so we actually find
this in Matthew 12: 31 and 32 and it
says therefore I say to you every sin
and blasphemy will be forgiven men but
the blasphemy against against the holy
spirit will not be forgiven men anyone
who speaks a word against the son of man
it will be forgiven him but whoever
speaks against the Holy Spirit it will
not be forgiven him either in this age
or in the age to come so we kind of need
to identify some of the the roles or the
purpose of the Holy Spirit we find in
John chapter 14 that the Holy Spirit
teaches us we also find that the Spirit
guides us into all truth in John chapter
16 and additionally in John chapter 16
we find that the Holy Spirit and this is
extremely important convicts us of sins
so we know that we can actually grieve
the Holy Spirit Paul tells us about this
in Ephesians chapter 4 and verse 30
which says and do not grieve the holy
spirit of God by whom you were sealed
for the day of redemption now I'm just
going to go out on a limb here and say
that everyone here on this table at one
point or another has grieved the holy
spirit so The Grieving in and of itself
is not the unpardonable sin what we need
to realize that it is the continuous
grieving of the Holy Spirit um think of
it kind of like this you know Pastor
John you grew up and were originally
raised in a very large city correct so
what kind of sounds would you hear in
that kind of uh environment wow cars
cars shouting music singing Everything
we're bombarded by media from every
direction right and I imagine because
you grew up there though you really
didn't hear those sounds too much going
to sleep at night no for someone like me
got used to it if I would go there I
would have a difficulty sleeping because
I'm going to hear all the sirens I'm
going to hear all the hustle and bustle
of the city and that's kind of what it's
like when you begin to continuously
grieve the holy spirit is you stop
hearing those things you stop hearing
the guidance of the Holy Spirit and
you're no longer convicted what you
previously thought was grotesque what
you previously thought with sin where
where you started to feel grief about it
you no longer do that anymore and you
start to justify it in your own mind so
you'll come to a point then where you
will no longer receive that conviction
and without repentance and true
conversion that is what the unpardonable
sin is we're told in 1 John 1:9 if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us of our sins but we have to
actually confess them in sincere
repentance and we know that God's spirit
will not strive with us forever forever
because we're even told in Genesis 6:3
that his spirit will not strive with us
so we can come to a point where we're
continuously uh grieving the Holy Spirit
and that right there because we're have
no longer can repent we no longer can
con uh receive conversion that we have
now grieved the Holy Spirit and cannot
be forgiven of things that we are not
repentant of thank you there's a
movement in America that is anti holy
spirit that is from the Devil Himself be
careful do not grieve the holy spirit
thank you so much now
Pastor LMA Kang this is a interesting
question is it proper to wear skin tyght
jeans as a wife or attend a marathon on
the
Sabbath wow you know this is a this is a
a Hot Topic so let me try to address it
uh with uh care and uh concern for
things that I may or may not know okay
let's talk about I think the focal point
here is Modesty yes because the person
talk about skin jeans and marathons and
there was also an illusion there about
person being uh a wife of a pastor and
this is something that was cautious to
me because we know as a pastor's wife
I'll give you one story very quickly my
wife and I we go go to places around the
world and we were invited to uh one of
the countries in Africa and there was a
fear among the ladies that they didn't
tell us until the time of the at the end
of the meetings they came to my my wife
and commended her for dressing modestly
because they said when we heard that a
speaker was coming from America we were
concerned about how his wife would dress
because America has establish a very
sensual non-biblical standard for the
way that people tend to dress and mostly
women very very revealing tight clingy
clothing that um as it is in some of our
schools as was at oood University if you
was something that was hugging you they
said women should wear what they call
regulation blouses used to uh used to
but now nowadays uh so many things have
changed that the world has molded the
way that many people dress particularly
in this case about modest stressed among
women let me tell you what the Bible
says and this is so vitally important I
did a seminar for families in I was in a
in Miami Florida and I made the
statement about a a person who is
complaining about how the women dressed
that were on the rostrom short dresses
tight uh very revealing and I said
ladies do what you can to help your
brothers make the kingdom
I'll repeat that do what you can to help
your brethren think about Jesus when
they come to church yes and that's so
vitally important in our society today
because the world has molded the way
that people dress particularly women and
sensuality is the most that the focus is
who could look at me look at Instagram
it's all about sensuality it's all about
I want to get the attention that belongs
to God alone you're not glorifying God
by the way you dress when you are
following the patterns of the world so
Paul's uh encouragement to Timothy is
this 1 Timothy 2:9 in like manner also
that the women Adorn themselves in
modest apparel yes don't ask yourself if
it's modest ask somebody else if it's
modest because many of us make the
standard based on the way we see things
and not the way that it really is Right
verse 10 but which is proper for women
professing godliness with good works so
the way that you dress when you go out
in society or when you leave your home
will a person think more about you or
would they think more about the Lord
very important and that's why Paul says
whether you therefore eat or drink or
whatever you do do all to the glory of
God are we allowing the standards of the
world to be the method by which we think
God will be glorified or are we allowing
God's word to be the point so lastly
Romans 12:
1-2 be not conformed to this world but
be transformed why present your body as
a Living Sacrifice holy and accept
acceptable to God which is your
reasonable service and lastly when the
Lord called Jacob and his family to be
dedicated at bethl he said this to his
family in Genesis 35:2 put away the
foreign gods that are among you purify
yourselves and change your garments we
cannot wear worldly garments that that
awaken thoughts of sensuality and
immorality if we are planning on giving
God the glory very important let the
word of God be the standard by which you
dress okay thank you for that kind of
lengthy but I needed yeah not much time
so we're going to go right into our
question to uh to Daniel Daniel why does
Zachariah
144 tell us the Lord shall stand upon
the Mount of Olives and first
Thessalonians
4:16-17 indicates that the Lord will not
touch this Earth upon his return this is
from Heather well Heather Jesus comes to
this earth more than one time Jesus
first first coming to this Earth was as
a baby there we read about that in the
story in Matthew and Luke now Jesus
Second Coming is what's referred to in
first Thessalonians 4:16 and 17 I'd love
to read it for the Lord himself will
descend from heaven with a shout and
with the voice of the Archangel and with
the trumpet of God and the dead in
Christ will rise first then we who are
alive and remain will be caught up
together with them in the clouds to meet
the Lord in the air and so he's not
touching the Earth we meet him in the
air and so we will always be with the
Lord and so this is Jesus second coming
when he returns to this earth to rescue
those who are both dead and alive
bringing them to heaven now the third
coming of Jesus is actually what
Zechariah is seeing in chapter 14 and
this is after the thousand years that's
referred to that's described in
Revelation CH 20 in Revelation 21:2 uh
describes the New Jerusalem the dwelling
of God with his people descending to
Earth and this is what Zechariah seas in
Zechariah 14:4 and his feet shall stand
in that day upon the Mount of Olives
which is before Jerusalem on the East
and the Mount of Olives shall cleave in
the midst thereof toward the East and
toward the west and there shall be a
very great valley and half of the
mountain shall be shall remove toward
the North and half of it toward the
South I want you to know that when Jesus
sets foot on this Earth the Earth itself
changes uh it's never the same again sin
will be destroyed finally uh when Jesus
returns Returns the third time with all
the saints in the holy city and uh the
Earth will be changed and so God wants
that experience for your life too him
dwelling with you now all right thank
you for that we're going to go right
into Ian's
question John 3:13 says no man hath
ascended to heaven but he that came down
from heaven even the son of man which is
in heaven where is Enoch and Elijah this
is from John in Oregon all right John in
Oregon I hope you're listening up
because this is going to be pretty quick
yeah um so but I do need to provide
Clarity to John uh 313 in order to
answer the question of where is Enoch
and Elijah so at first glance I know
this uh verse can be a little confusing
I know it was for the first time that I
actually read it so I'm going to do my
best to explain it to you but if you
look again uh at the context of what is
taking place here in John chapter 3
Jesus is actually speaking with
Nicodemus and Jesus is you know uh
trying to explain that he's not here to
build a uh a temporal Kingdom he's
actually here to build a spiritual
Kingdom and he's explaining also to
Nicodemus Nicodemus about being born
again and some of these concepts are
actually foreign to Nicodemus he doesn't
really understand it and so what's
taking place in John chter 3 and13 in
this verse that you're asking in
question is Jesus is really explaining
who he is and how he can speak of these
things that are spiritual because Jesus
is the only man who has come down from
heaven
who has ascended into heaven and was
here as as a man the reason why and you
can see this is in John chapter one it
talks about in the beginning was the
word the word being Jesus and the Word
was with God and the Word was God and in
the beginning was God so you're seeing
the same language that's also taking
place here as well as Genesis CH 1 and
verse one where it says in the beginning
God so Jesus was actually there at
creation you could see that Jesus was
there at the burning bush because in
John chapter 8 Jesus was first to
himself in verse 58 as before Abraham
was I am and which is the same language
again that's being used in Exodus 3:14
with Moses at the burning bush it was
Jesus who gave the children of Israel
water to drink in the wilderness Paul
confirms this in 1 Corinthians chap 10
and verse 4 where it says for they drank
of the spiritual rock that followed them
and that rock was Christ you can read
about that in Exodus 17 as well we see
that Jesus is referring to as the angel
of the Lord who had came down he spoke
to Moses again in Exodus chapter 3 but
also Gideon in chapter 6 and in the
story of Samson so Jesus again is the
only one who has come down from heaven
has ascended into heaven and is here as
the son of man so where is Enoch and
Elijah they're exactly where the Bible
says that they are and that is in heaven
with God so this verse is not talking
about that there is no one in heaven but
rather it is justifying that Jesus is
the only one who can can speak of these
spiritual and Heavenly things because he
has been there since the beginning amen
thank you for that well we're going to
take a quick break so stay tuned we'll
be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible qa3
[Music]
abn.com back I hope you were blessed I
was blessed I always learn something new
with this program well for final
thoughts Pastor LOM Kang what's your
final thought well the question about
dress also included about going to a
marathon on Sabbath and let me just go
ahead and and make a very important
point and I'm so glad that Daniel laid
the foundation about explaining which
day is the Sabbath which is the seventh
day of the week which some countries you
might say it's Sunday no but it's
Saturday the Bible Sabbath Isaiah 58
makes it very clear if you you turn away
your foot from the Sabbath from doing
your pleasure on my holy day and the
question was can we go to marathons well
the Bible doesn't give allowance for
marathons nor does he give allowance for
baseball games or football games or
anything that is of a nature that is not
Sanctified one of the best ways you can
understand how to honor the Sabbath is
it's God's day would you say to your
wife I know it's our anniversary honey
but I have more important things to do
you'll just have to wait if we would not
do that to our spouse we don't do that
to God and the most important thing the
Sabbath is a sign between us and God and
he says not finding your own Pleasures
nor speaking your own words and even
those who do honor the Sabbath must
brush upon the reality that it's not
your day just because you go to church
on that day but that day is a day that
we do by all of our activity bring honor
and glory to God read Isaiah
58:13 thank you so much well the Bible
says sanctify them by thy truth your
truth truth your word is truth until
next time continue to trust in Jesus
thank you for joining us
[Music]